you guys go down in lifestyle for a
family
so say
no Nails no hair very little makeup
budget but you get a man for a lifetime
loyal he's everything you want but you
have to go down in lifestyle you maybe
get what what's you pick the amount they
get a month for recreational Auntie's
better with the budgeting recreational
for them for the whole household or just
for them for them I think they get to
spend on themselves everything else is
the kids or the family 500 a month 500
pounds a month
to be with a perfect man yeah yeah maybe
not pert let's no man's perfect but he
does everything that I need him to do
yeah but you live in where do they live
auntie I think Auntie's going to give
the better picture where do they live
they live in Kennington in a tablet
yeah so you go from you go from say like
a house a big house in like Primrose
Hill
on your own
to go into a tower Block in Cannington
with your perfect man and your perfect
family
but in order to do that don't forget
your building with him
but in order to do that you're not
allowed to no Nails no makeup because
you can't afford it just yet how often
how often can they go out with the girls
you've mentioned going out with girls no
how often can they go out it could be
just like a dinner or like whatever any
kind of full dinner you'd invite the
girls in for a night in oh a night and
how often can they do that once a month
once a month yeah so it's either that or
I'm just on my own basis or you go out
with him yeah to be if I'm being
completely honest but he's your perfect
man perfect like you've got two kids
perfect I'll be comfortable like it's
not the kids are paid for it you're the
only thing you can't they can't afford
is you're upkeep
I'd rather I'd rather the family to be
honest family wait so I can't get my
hair done
I just would say what makeup nothing
nothing for how long is that like for as
long as it takes for you to get out of
the kids till the kids are let's say 10.
all right I'll say 15. I'll compromise
13. there's no like divorce inside like
this is my perfect match this is you
know I mean
you're still gonna fight you know a bit
you're still you know human you'll fight
you know now and then but overall a good
man
but yeah for 13 years you can you can't
really go out your friends can only come
to you that's really it
uh I mean I already have my perfect
mindset that mine I don't necessarily
need to do all the hair nails makeup
because he's already there so I guess I
would take the family and the man yeah
yeah family all day how should you wear
makeup for do you make up for yourself
do you do a little bit for yourself or
do you do it to look attractive to men
no I don't do it to attract men or
anything I do it for myself because I do
love hair and makeup and I do love
getting my nails done it just I'm just
used to doing that
you just say yeah
because you wouldn't normally would go
into a club with no makeup on in your
bald head Queen Rose No One's Gonna Do
it when you go out yeah you dress
yourself up to attract the opposite
itself do you do it to feel good too
however you do it for the op for the
opposing person so if I've already got
my man if he accepts me with no wig no
makeup bashes Nails then I'm good to be
fair yeah exactly that's basically yeah
no makeup on my hair back and stuff like
that I've done it I've done it and I've
just done it because I want to go out
and listen to music I don't care about
being attractive to no one because I
don't care I just want to drink and just
to enjoy music so I've done it but then
again I don't wear makeup
we'll get my nails done
well dude you know somebody needs to
give me a makeover I want one of them
big old wigs I want to get eyelashes I
want to see how different I look I want
makeup I want to get the nails done what
do you think Pearl give me on makeover
an auntie makeover yeah and yeah
anti-anti makeover anti-makeover I think
oh we could do that one yeah when
Melanie King comes to town she could
Style Both of Us yeah something
hmm
do you do you think people do you think
everyone
um
this is another thing I got in trouble
for
they come for me for no reason really
honestly so do you think everyone
deserves love
no
yeah you think everyone deserves love
yeah what about
Hitler
uh he's going inside
his own family would have that he would
have love for his own family that's it
but he doesn't deserve love from like
anyone else do you think yeah everyone
deserves love
I mean some people deserve to be
tolerated some people deserve to be
liked but not everybody deserve to be
loved okay so we think that they don't
do you think they had love in their life
though Hitler had someone Jeffrey had
somebody regardless everybody no but
they still had it but it's not designed
they had it but they didn't deserve it
it could be sick love you don't think
love is earned
um life should be young depending on who
it comes from it should be unconditional
like a mother and child it should be
unconditional love you shouldn't have to
earn your parents love I think I think
that you're I think children deserve
love but I don't think adults deserve
love
why not I think everyone deserves to
know what love feels like unconditional
she means
adults don't you you could love somebody
but you may not like them which you know
what I mean and I think that's a
difference I think a love is an
extremely strong emotion that we kind of
underrate because you can be in we've
done it I'm sure you know I've been in a
relationships like I shouldn't have
loved that person but I did because it's
it's an emotion that's created you know
I'm saying it's not earned you create
love you said you can love someone but
not necessarily like them yeah I think
the other way around so you could like
somebody but not love them yeah I tend
to that's easy I tend to dislike anybody
but save the love for special people but
some people like certain family like
parents for example
um I love my dad because he's my dad but
I don't like him as a person you can
love someone
but not necessarily like the person that
they are now you just say I'd like him
because he's my dad's and that's what
society says no but I love him because
of certain there's certain memories and
stuff you have with that with particular
people about my parents I like my dad
because he's my dad
that's it
Nelson he's a bad dad but just that I
love my grandchildren
that's it love is a sick thing as well
like I think love is just so complex do
I mean because it's like let's stay away
from the family love because that's like
easy let's stick to the kind of romantic
love
which I mean I I don't know why for some
reason I've just got like pimp and
in my head I don't know why but it's
like these men you know abuse these
women but they fall in love I don't know
it's so strange like like I said love is
it's sickening you can't sometimes you
can't work out you can't comprehend it
with the minds it is literally an energy
or an emotion so it's not infatuation or
something it could be
is it infatuation is that love
what's that is Stockholm Stockholm
syndrome yeah when you love your captor
yeah just love comes in many shapes and
forms me like we'll all sit here as
different people that's the mental
illness isn't it Stockholm syndrome
that's meant all love so okay is love in
the mind or is it in the body we really
had to do that because before what would
they do they would kill if one tribe
overtook another tribe they would kill
the children and the men and take the
women so like women had to evolutionary
like if they wanted to pass on their
genes they had to fall in love with
their captor also it's like a coping
mechanism essentially oh I don't know
it's like arranged marriages also I
don't know if that's the same thing
it's about it's like lions and the Cubs
you know when when the tribes take over
and then you say Arrangements all kinds
of because some of those people in their
cultures they don't have a choice like
whoever they're given to that's who they
and it's still real to this day that's
that's not that's not what arranged
marriages are like what is it what is it
like they have a choice they get the
people and they actually have a choice
okay it's not like this is a person
you're gonna marry him they say this is
what we're looking for in a man that's
what we're looking for in a woman and
the families talk and eventually they
meet and if they don't like each other
they say I don't like them and then they
go and choose again I don't know I think
in some countries
um maybe not so much here but in some
countries I think that they don't have a
choice these young girls that are given
to these older men I don't think they
have a choice when the family sell them
for money and stuff
personally I think that definitely does
exist that's an exception but that's not
that's not what umbrella's marriages
actually are word that's abuse would you
guys consider yourself modern or
traditional
modern women are traditional women
um
identify falling there's I still have a
lot of traditional
um values but I also
do have a lot of modern takes on things
so I don't I don't think I fall into
either bracket to be fair could you tell
me how are you modern how are you
traditional so like what Traditional
Values do you have and like what about
you is modern
um traditional in a sense of I feel like
um women should
take care of house and home and I feel
like men should be providers of a
household
um
however I do also feel like in this day
and age
I'm not I don't really like calling
people or or anything or
things like that like if you wanna
whoever you want to see if it's who you
want to sleep with like it doesn't so
you're more modern because you're not
judgmental yeah essentially okay but you
do believe in women taking care of the
home and men going to off to work
basically no definitely I feel like
women I feel like it's as women you
should know how to cook food you should
know how to clean a house you should
know how to just those basic things I
think that's forgotten a lot in this in
this day and age women don't know how to
cook food or just they'll know how to
drink and go out partying but don't know
how to season food or green chicken or
anything like that I think that needs
that's not something that's as common
anymore
for me I'd say I'm more traditional I
would only say a modern in the sense of
I don't like to judge people
but I'm definitely more traditional in
the sense of like you know
keeping yourself to marriage taking care
of the household the children letting
the man be the brain like um The
Breadwinner things like that
um so yeah what traditional skills do
you have
um can you sell uh yeah I can actually
say you can sell yeah I learned how to
sew when I was a kid so what else I
cleaned the house I cook
um yeah just take care of the home
really like I'm always cleaning at home
so are you a virgin
no no not that one okay go ahead okay if
we're gonna go traditional okay go ahead
I think when it comes to matters of the
heart I'm more traditional
um what makes me a modern woman is the
fact that I'm you know pursuing a career
basically without relying on a guy
so you would
pick one
traditional you're a traditional woman
okay yeah team I'm a traditionalist
a bit of modern gadgets
[Laughter]
so yeah I'm not traditional I'm not
modern I'm this a traditionalist
attenter
like the traditional stuff
I tend to try and follow that way they
want to know in the chat what cultural
dishes
um because everyone said they could cook
what cultural dishes can you cook
um Frosty chicken rice calorie curry
chicken roti
dalid
Trinidadian okay what traditional or
what um cultural dishes can you cook
well I'm Congolese so I'll make rice and
put you at home and for the Congo these
people they'll know okay what else what
else
um well a lot of Congolese is like
fondue Madison I'm not sure a lot of
people know about that unless you're
congrelease yourself
um yeah it's a little right this rice
dishes also like a lot of pasta dishes
um yeah but okay what about you um so my
Heritage is Jamaican and British
um but my ex-husband was Colombian so I
learned a lot how to infuse so anything
from scratch really whether that's a
fried English breakfast or a pasta meal
or a chicken stew or you know any of
anything from scratch there's love and
passion do you think traditional women
are virgins foreign
if you're going to use if you're going
to take the word as it is then yeah yeah
no I'm not I don't think so no no what
do you think can't do I've been the
traditional word for traditional women
is Virgin I think that traditional women
are virgins I'll tell you why because
traditional is putting the family before
yourself right and I think the most if
we're gonna like do the archetype of
like ideal traditional women they're
thinking about the family from the time
they're like 12 13 14 so they don't want
to have sex with anyone else because
other than their husband
because they don't want to bring that
into a marriage so if we're going to do
like the ideal archetype of like what is
the ideal traditional woman I I would
argue it's probably a virgin
I agree because they're they're thinking
Family First from like a very young age
they would never get divorced
um career really isn't first for that
like it's always family before career
everything's Family First
is there anything else you guys would
add to that that I missed
as far as being traditional yeah
I think like her attitude as well
towards her man um yeah that's a good
one then trying to dominate or be in
control or even be equal is that yeah
it's about being able to submit to your
man your husband okay it's sex on tap
I think that sits on tap when he wants
it as much as possible I think that's
what a lot of women will struggle with
what do you struggle with
can traditional women cheat ever no if
they're traditional then no no as many
of you
know if he's just been
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible